fast sechs monate krieg in der ukraine
und auch heute wollen wir uns die
militärische lage im land ansehen und
ansehen mit welchen waffen denn beide
seiten versuchen einen vorteil zu
erringen erst mal zur militärischen lage
dort ist es weiterhin relativ
festgefahren wir haben in den letzten
tagen weitere russischer angriff hier im
osten gesehen dort versucht man
verzweifelt aus russischer sicht von der
region luhansk die man hier eingenommen
hat diese große region im osten eben in
die region donetsk ihr vorzudringen und
die steht des klobigen zum kantors zu
erobern das hatte man sich eigentlich
gesetzt dass man es innerhalb von einem
oder zwei monaten bis mitte august
schafft das ist völlig unrealistisch
trotzdem gibt es hier weiter rosig im
vorstöße und man versucht weiter mit
aller kraft dort vorzubringen wir
versuchen dass beide seiten es sind vor
allem die schweren waffen die eine
wichtige rolle spielen und man kann
tatsächlich sagen dass es nach dem nach
dem prinzip ja größer weiter besser
sozusagen geht die russen haben ihre
alte sowjetische artillerie dorthin
geschafft wir sehen hier neue aufnahmen
aus propaganda abteilungen der
russischen armee das ist die gea zb eine
152 millimeter artillerie also sehr
große sehr großes geschoss was ungefähr
27 km weit schießt und wir sehen uns
jetzt auch gleich wie eben aus festen
position und das ist auch interessant
wir mittlerweile feste grenze position
wenn man so möchte hier geschossen wurde
auf die ukrainischen stellung die
ukraine versuchen dem entgegenzuhalten
natürlich vor allem mit dem westlichen
waffen und hier sehen wir noch mal diese
diese kooperation wenn man so will von
kleinen drohnen wirklich quadcopter an
wie man sie auch ja auch in deutschland
im supermarkt oder jetzt sogar im
supermarkt bekommt und eben dieser
schweren artillerie dort wird eben
versucht dass man für diesen drohen
genau sieht wo ist der feind jetzt ist
ja dieses z ja das set für die russische
invasion sozusagen dort darauf gehofft
projiziert und dann schießt diese m 777
diese politische artillerie die jedoch
aus den usa geliefert wurde an die
ukraine schießt eben auf die jeweiligen
orte und man kann tatsächlich sehen wie
innerhalb von kürzester zeit daneben
nachdem nach der sicht eines russischen
fahrzeuges oder eines russischen hauses
dann auch das jeweilige haus getroffen
wird das ist also tatsächlich tödlicher
präzision die wir sehen aber die ukraine
haben diese m 77 zwar in ihrem in ihren
in ihrem potenzial aber sie hat eine
relativ kurze reichweite muss man sagen
etwa 22 kilometer 23 kilometer das ist
weniger als die gier zb die wm gesehen
haben und deshalb setzen die ukraine
eben auf diese waffen die sogenannte
high maß dieser amerikanischen
präzisions raketen und hier sehen wir
wie vier stück davon ihre sechs raketen
abschießen heimers etwa 70 kilometer
reichweite sehr sehr große raketen sehr
genau und das interessante ist auch was
das kostet also was ich nicht in der
ukraine sondern auch wieder was die
verbündeten ebenfalls die usa sich das
kosten lassen jede dieser raketen
diversen kostet 150000 euro dh wenn wir
viele systeme haben die jeweils ihre
sechs raketen abschießen sind das 24
raketen 3,6 millionen euro die hier in
die luft geschossen werden so viel
kostet der kampf gegen putins regime der
kampf für die unabhängigkeit der ukraine
und insofern geht es tatsächlich nach
diesem motto größer weiter unten dann
auch besser was eben die waffen die
schweren waffen angeht die die ukraine
weiterhin sehr dringend benötigt